US intelligence sources say there is new
evidence that Iran shot down a civilian
passenger jet in its own airspace
killing many of its own citizens this
video obtained by the New York Times
seems to show the impact and you can see
a bright flash in the sky which our
sources tell us was actually the
explosion of two surface-to-air missiles
surveillance cameras picked up a shower
of debris from the Ukrainian plane the
crash just after takeoff from Tehran's
main airport killing all 176 people on
board
it happened just hours after Iran's
missile attack on US troops in Iraq
Tehran denies it shot down the aircraft
it invited the u.s. to send an
investigator to the scene we're covering
all the angles of this story Kris Van
Cleave has new information on the
investigation but first we go to
Elizabeth Palmer in Tehran who has just
been to the site of the crash Liz what's
of the Iranian government saying well
they're sticking to their initial
statement there was another news
conference this morning in which they
repeated that denial that an Iranian
missile could have brought down the
Ukrainian plane videos shot by witnesses
appear to show the plane flying along on
fire than an explosion
a little over 48 hours later we've
arrived at what the local people say is
the crash site there are no guards here
nobody tried to stop us coming in in
fact there are people all over some
looking for things of value to take away
some just reflecting on what's happened
there isn't much of the plane left local
people say that trucks cranes showed up
and took most of the pieces that were
here away clearly this is an impact
crater behind me another one over there
but they're empty at the moment it
doesn't appear that the Ukrainian
investigators have come to the site and
whatever evidence was here is just not
here anymore
there should be a wealth of evidence in
the black boxes which Iran is looking at
today and has promised to share with the
Ukrainians the boxes may contain some
answers for the grieving families of
those who died 63 of them Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau the families of
the victims and all Canadians want
answers I want answers Omid our Salah
need lost his sister and her family in
the crash every moment I'm gonna wake up
and it's a nightmare and it's over and
she's home and I'm gonna her door a
veteran Air accident investigator has
told me that if this were the United
States or say Europe that crash site
would never have been cleared so quickly
but the international regulations
governing this sort of thing state
clearly that Iran has a right to manage
this investigation as it sees fit Gayle
oh boy Elizabeth Palmer it's very tough
to look at those pictures because it's a
crash site but it's also a grave site
remains of people's families that's very
tough to look at thank you very much
you